the Lincoln Theater stage seems custom
made for British songstress Yola and her
genre fluid style I love The Narrative
of places like this that just give so
much life to music it's a nod to the
storied history of the theater and its U
Street home the cultural epicenter of a
thriving African-American Community here
we have black Broadway another hotbed of
black culture of development of jazz
music as well all the things that
surround our influenced and touched by
jazz music
um happening right here
and so like it's really significant to
be here
the Lincoln Theater opened in January of
1922 and offered audiences Refuge from
the indignities of a segregated ERA this
is uh an incredible space
thank you we really try to retain as
much of the historical element as
possible Charisse Rines runs the new
Lincoln Theater I think it's very
Majestic and boast about its original
Heyday any chance she gets we kind of
predated the Renaissance that people
refer to in Harlem and there was a huge
music scene in DC people such as
Pearl Bailey Cab Calloway Duke Ellington
performed here and set the standard for
what live music was like in this area
below the theater a dancehall called the
Lincoln Colonnade hosted social events
for all FDR used to have birthday
parties here as in Franklin Delano
Roosevelt our 32nd president he liked
this space he did like this space and
there were people from different
backgrounds that would attend those
parties so people felt like segregation
was taking a holiday at those events
outside the jewel of U Street all that
culture fostered a neighborhood of black
run and black owned businesses some that
remain today you have bands who's been
neighbors to the theater for what yes
seven years yeah so the Lincoln Theater
was very important to the community and
certainly a very important to be in me
Virginia Ali and her husband Ben opened
Ben's Chili Bowl in 1958 right next door
to the Lincoln Theater sometimes you
could go in and smell chili dogs because
they would have snuck the chili though
in the Lincoln Theater yes but it was
it's been a wonderful asset to this
community here for all these 100 years
but the history of this area also
includes decline riots in 1968 stirred
by the assassination of Martin Luther
King Jr construction for the D.C metro
in the late 1970s and Rising competition
elsewhere all forced the closure of the
Lincoln in 1983. until the city fought
for its preservation it reopened in
February 1994 after being named to the
National register for historic places
and again in 2013 under a new operator
box office giant imp what's your
favorite spot in the theater you know I
really like this fireplace area upgrades
were made to the 1250 seat venue
including a state-of-the-art sound
system and a multi-million dollar
renovation we really try to keep it as
Regal as it was in the 20s it's already
booked a thousand shows here attracting
more than six hundred thousand patrons
we have had rock concerts we've had
country music concerts we've had a
Mexican ballet we've had a go-go
showcase
wow church every Sunday really and we've
had
um drag shows I take pride in the fact
that this is a venue where you can look
at the calendar and almost anybody from
any background with any interest can
find something on the calendar that
would interest them with plenty more
they say to come we have such a diverse
offering of
performances
and of genres
and audiences too and of audiences as
well which to me is a reflection of the
legacy of what the theater was built for